ben non ce n'est simplement pas le
moment de lever le confinement cette
semaine le déconfinement pas encore pour
tout le monde
si plusieurs pays européens autorisent
peu à peu leurs citoyens à sortir de
chez eux et les britanniques devront
encore patienter plusieurs semaines
jusqu'au 1er juin au moins une stratégie
basée sur une levée progressive des
mesures précisées par le chef du
gouvernement britannique au plus tôt le
1er juin nous pensons que nous pourrons
être en mesure de commencer la
réouverture progressive des magasins et
de ramener des élèves du primaire dans
les écoles au plus tôt au mois de
juillet sous réserve que toutes ces
conditions soient remplies en suivant
l'avis des scientifiques
si et seulement si les chiffres le
justifie nous espérons rouvrir au moins
une partie de l'industrie hôtelière et
d'autres lieux publics la condition
qu'il soit sûr et qu'ils imposent une
distanciation sociale une fausse une
allocution loin de convaincre le
travailliste kirsch starmer le chef de
file de l'opposition pointe un manque de
clarté et bien je pense que ce que le
pays voulait ce soir était dur et la
clarté et un sens du consensus et je
crains que nous n'ayons pas obtenu cela
le message de base rester vigilant à
n'est tout simplement pas assez clair il
y avait plus de questions que de
réponses dans les déclarations du
premier ministre et nous avons
maintenant à la perspective de
l'angleterre de l'ecosse du pays galles
avec des messages différents à certains
tirant dans des directions différentes
et donc la carte et le consensus ne sont
pas larges apprécié le fait qu'il y aura
bientôt plus de détails
il y aura d'autres questions à poser
mais pour l'instant il ya un fossé entre
ce dont nous avions vraiment besoin ce
soir et ce que nous avons obtenu plus
tôt
certains citoyens britanniques
s'inquiétaient d'un assouplissement trop
hâtif des règles sanitaires
est-ce que je pense que le confinement
doit se poursuivre oui je pense
commencer pas suffisamment tous les
jours il ya de nouvelles choses qui
sortent maintenant il a le jeune enfant
qui ont été touchés et des adolescents
qui font des embolies pulmonaires
chaque fois que je sors travail et
surtout les deux derniers jours où il a
fait beau il ya du monde partout dans la
rue et je ne crois pas que ce soit
acceptable vraiment je pense que les
règles devraient être un petit peu plus
strictes et jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait un
peu plus de sécurité
je pense qu'on pourra alors se demander
quand on doit assouplir le confinement
mais pas pour l'instant je ne crois pas
que les gens écoutent vraiment en
parallèle le gouvernement envisage
d'utiliser un système de traçage et
souhaite augmenter sa capacité de
dépistage espérant réaliser 200 mille
tests quotidiens d'ici la fin du mois de
mai outre-manche la population est
confinée depuis le 23 mars dernier